[Música]
se acaba el título 42 en Estados Unidos
esta política le permitía a las
autoridades expulsar rápidamente a los
migrantes que cruzaban de manera ilegal
la frontera con México sin darles la
oportunidad de que se quedaran en suelo
estadounidense para pedir un asilo
Aunque la medida se implementó en 2020
durante el gobierno de Donald Trump con
el argumento de controlar la pandemia de
Kobe 19 con ella aumentó el número de
devoluciones y ahora que se acaba el
título 42 miles de extranjeros se
agolparon en las fronteras con la
esperanza de no ser deportados por eso
Alejandro mayorcas el secretario de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
reiteró que las puertas no están
abiertas
quiero ser muy claro nuestras fronteras
no están abiertas las personas que
crucen nuestras fronteras ilegalmente y
sin una base legal para permanecer serán
procesadas y expulsadas de inmediato
una persona que es expulsada bajo el
título 8 está sujeta al menos cinco años
de prohibición de reingreso a los
Estados Unidos
y puede enfrentar un proceso penal si
intenta cruzar nuevamente
la mayoría de los migrantes que fueron
expulsados de Estados Unidos bajo el
título 42 fueron enviados a México ante
el fin de la medida del presidente de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador afirmó que
seguirán cooperando con la Casa Blanca
cooperar con el gobierno de Estados
Unidos para que no haya
[Música]
caos y mucho menos violencia
en la frontera
estamos nosotros
ayudando en el sureste para que
se proteja a migrantes para analizar
este tema tenemos a tres invitados en el
debate César niño nos acompaña en
nuestro estudio Aquí en Bogotá y es
profesor de relaciones internacionales
de la Universidad de La Salle en Miami
está Julio melling estratega republicano
y politólogo y en Washington está
Lawrence estratega demócrata y asesor
senior para latinoamérica de West Texas
advisores consultoría a ustedes nuestra
audiencia les recuerdo que también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar todos
los comentarios y las preguntas que
tengan a través de las redes sociales en
todas nos encuentran como arroba France
24 raya al piso ese y la etiqueta para
comentar es numeral el debate f-24 como
lo ven en sus pantallas a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
maríacle
que todos los contenidos de nuestro
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
de nuevo les doy entonces la bienvenida
Comenzando por César Gracias por
acompañarnos César Cómo explicarle a
alguien que no tiene ni idea del título
42 de Qué es esta medida muy brevemente
bueno Muchas gracias por la invitación
nuevamente
expira y termina como lo advertía el
secretario hace unos instantes y tiene
que ver con que culmina una medida
especial que no es nueva en los Estados
Unidos y que se había invocado por
primera vez en 1944 se invoca dentro del
marco de la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
consiste en efecto en que Estados Unidos
en términos de salud pública toma todas
las medidas necesarias para expulsar
cualquier tipo cualquier persona
cualquier actor que sea vector o
transmisor de alguna enfermedad que
atente contra la salud pública en
últimas nos vamos a dar cuenta que la
salud pública es casi que sinónimo para
los Estados Unidos como un asunto de
seguridad nacional ese título 42 termina
y por supuesto empieza el título ocho
que renueva nuevamente un ciclo de
diferentes aproximaciones sobre la idea
de y algo importante que aclarar que tal
vez el gobierno estadounidense ha
reiterado con tal vez con algunos
errores interpretativos y es que ningún
migrante es ilegal los migrantes son
irregulares exacto y ahora quiero
simplemente hacer una precisión sobre
algo que usted menciona y es la
diferencia entre el título 42 y el
título ocho y una de ellas por ejemplo
es que cuando los migrantes eran
expulsados de Estados Unidos bajo el
título 42 no enfrentaban procesos
penales por migración sin los documentos
requeridos mientras que por el título
ocho sí Y además se les prohíbe entrar a
Estados Unidos durante cinco años más es
decir es una medida más fuerte que el
título 42 le quiero dar la bienvenida a
Julio de messiling Gracias por
acompañarnos a usted Le quiero preguntar
concretamente Este título 42 es una
medida realmente para hacerle freno al
Coby 19 o era para impedir el derecho al
asilo
primero es un placer Me declaro estar
contigo
en France 24
siguiendo la ley Pues habían inquietudes
de salud pública bajo Este título Dos
punto seis millones de personas fueron
retornado a sus a la frontera sur o sea
fue retornado su respectivos países por
lo menos se le negó la entrada eh dos
millones seiscientos mil personas que
estaban entrando de manera ilegal y yo
Yo entiendo
la cuestión semántica y y el uso
posmodernista que se le quiera dar Pero
la realidad es que en las leyes
norteamericanas Pues en eso son claras Y
parte del éxito que tuvo la
administración previa en evitar el caos
y la gran Crisis que hay en este momento
en la frontera Sur es precisamente
utilizar una herramienta como el título
42 o sea el Yo creo que el punto de que
si fue utilizado Más allá de razones de
salubridad bueno los políticos
constantemente
utilizan leyes existentes como de
espionaje de traición y mil cosas para
con determinados fines yo creo que eso
pues llevó a cabo una política
inmigratoria de que por lo menos estaba
reforzando las leyes existentes No es
que no existen leyes existen y la actual
administración Simplemente no ha
cumplido las leyes ahora
mandado a correr Pues están desesperados
porque es un año se acerca un año de
elección y sabe que van a pagar un
precio por eso y sin duda es un tema que
discutiremos aquí en el debate de todas
estas políticas para reducir la
migración Cómo están relacionadas con
las elecciones presidenciales de Estados
Unidos pero antes le quiero preguntar a
lorens si para él es o si para usted es
una medida el título 42 contra el 19 o
era para evitar el derecho al asilo
bueno María Clara Muchas gracias y
gracias a Frank 24 por esta invitación
claramente el señor Trump llegó a la
presidencia
prometiendo que iba a frenar la
migración y se frustró cuando no podía
conseguir su pared cuando cuando tenía
algunos éxitos pero no era tanto como él
quiso con la llegada de covid entró una
manera muy creativa y tengo que admitir
efectivo
utilizando el título 42 para básicamente
expulsar a los los migrantes y regulares
una manera más eficaz porque
definitivamente nuestro sistema es muy
ineficiente en cuanto a tratar esas
migrantes pero en el fondo
fue utilizado y manipulado tenía sus
bases de salud especialmente al
principio de la pandemia pero después la
pandemia estaba bajo control era obvio
que seguía con título 42
básicamente únicamente porque era muy
eficaz y y la alternativa no fue muy
agradable para los políticos y de hecho
presidente cuando llegó al poder se dio
cuenta también que era muy difícil
acabar con las los mecanismos de título
Por qué era algo muy sensible y
políticamente en los Estados Unidos y
demoró mucho hasta ahora en por fin
porque declaró el fin de pandemia usted
muestra entonces las dificultades que
tuvo Joe biden para acabar el título 42
como lo prometió en campaña sin embargo
también muestra que fue una medida o
usted dice que fue una medida manipulada
y utilizada por el gobierno republicano
de Donald Trump para contener los Le
quiero preguntar César Por qué vaiden se
demoró tanto en acabar el título 42 Y si
está de acuerdo o no con con los
panelistas anteriores Y es una
manipulación o si es la medida que
existe legalmente bueno que sea legal no
significa que sea legítimo No eso es muy
muy interesante tenerlo sobre la mesa yo
creo que también algo que hay que anotar
Es que la administración Trump en años
anteriores buscó la forma de
materializar una forma de enemigo y lo
digo básicamente con que la pandemia era
algo tan gaseoso también un poco tan
intangible que la única manera de darle
cuerpo a esa pandemia en términos de
materializar un enemigo era
efectivamente en cuerpo de los migrantes
y la migración como un asunto asumido
como un asunto de exclusivo de seguridad
nacional es interesante verlo desde ese
punto de vista porque eso es lo que
hereda de pronto la administración biden
de desmontar Tal vez un poco abrupta
porque efectivamente progresivamente ha
sido bastante difícil el desmonte del
título 42 Y eso genera por supuesto lo
que decían a los panelistas
anteriormente de generar una sensación
de incertidumbre frente a las elecciones
que se aproximan Entonces yo creo que
aquí hay que ver algo sobre la mesa y es
que estamos hablando de seres humanos no
estamos hablando efectivamente de
cualquier otro fenómeno sino así como la
migración y el cambio climático
pareciera ser que son dos asuntos
interesantes que le preocuparon y
trasnocharon un poco la administración
Trump en su momento y que hereda de
alguna u otra manera una preocupación
trascendental la administración biden no
obstante insisto en algo Y es que la
materialización de ese Enemigo en cuerpo
ajeno lo digo es porque la la pandemia
la covid 19 que ha sido declarada
superada por la OMS en días anteriores
generan alguna u otra manera sensaciones
en las que efectivamente Estados Unidos
en la administración Trump tenía que
darle un cuerpo y materializar esa
amenaza en cuerpos de seres humanos es
decir el migrantes irregulares pero
usted habla de una materialización de la
supuesta amenaza y que ellos son los
migrantes sin embargo en la temporada de
gobierno de Joe biden la migración se
disparó el número de expulsiones en la
frontera con México no solo superó los
niveles de Trump que en 2019 duplicaron
las cifras de 2018 sino que las de biden
superaron todo esto Julio A qué se debe
entonces tanto el aumento de la
migración como el aumento de las
expulsiones
primero tengo que señalar que es muy
interesante y coincido en que lo legal
No necesariamente lo moral o lo legítimo
pero eso es aplicable a regímenes no
democráticos si entendemos que los
Estados Unidos es una democracia pues la
legitimidad parte del Estado de derecho
que refleja o sea los votantes los que
los representantes de la soberanía
Popular de modo de que es legítimo los
nombres que le queramos usar irregulares
Entonces los presos son también
ciudadanos irregulares que están en
casas
en vez de cárceles o sea podemos jugar
estos juegos posmodernistas semánticos
por la realidad es que son ilegales
están incumpliendo con la ley la mayor
parte de las personas que están viniendo
vienen bajo una aclamación de
persecución que realmente no aplicarían
o sea bajo ningún concepto pero eh en
contestar tu pregunta directamente es
porque tienen una luz verde si quieren
ver esto
pueden ver videos de ayer mismo en la
frontera Sur como
oficiales a la dirección de el gobierno
de Joe Byron están facilitando entrada a
personas le han abierto Las puertas
digan entren entren o sea aquí la razón
por la cual hay tres veces más personas
y legalmente cruzando la frontera sur de
los Estados Unidos es porque hay una
política que no se está aplicando no se
está cumpliendo la ley no se está y
dicho sea de paso hay que señalar que
esto fue un problema que también tuvo
la administración de Donald Trump en
porque el control resistencia de
determinada jurisdicciones que no
quisieron aplicar eso y solo un punto
María clara que esto es importante
entender noventa por ciento
de la droga particularmente el fentanilo
que entra en los Estados Unidos entra
por la frontera sur El la sobredosis de
fentanilo es la mayor causa de muerte
entre hombres entre las edades de
dieciocho a 45 años o sea que esto se
convierte en una cuestión de seguridad
nacional no es semántica es real y la
reacción que estamos viendo Es un poco
tarde porque la crisis se ha estado
montando tres veces la cantidad de
personas han cruzado y han cruzado
porque no se ha aplicado la ley
Sencillamente Eso sí muy brevemente el
derecho a la réplica para César legal o
Legítimo hace parte de otros regímenes
distintos a la democracia No pues por
supuesto es decir en regímenes
democráticos también hay derecho a
disentir sobre y a discernir por
supuesto sobre lo legítimo y lo y lo
legal no no todo no toda aplicación de
la ley efectivamente responde una
aceptación social a pesar de que la ley
efectivamente sea valga la redundancia
legal simplemente eso Y por supuesto es
importante mencionar que las condiciones
de lo que estamos viendo aquí frente al
crimen organizado que señalan pasando la
frontera Sur no solamente obedece a una
dinámica exclusivamente migratoria no la
redes criminales operan mucho más
organizadas que los propios estados
Ahora sí voy con usted Lawrence porque
Julio defiende reiteradamente que sí son
ciudadanos ilegales y que decir que
simplemente son indocumentados es un
juego semántico y él también afirma que
lo que está pasando Es que no se ha
cumplido la ley durante el gobierno
demócrata y que esa es la principal
causa por la que la migración se ha
disparado en los últimos años Usted qué
opina
eso no estoy de acuerdo con eso la
administración está cumpliendo con la
ley el problema fundamental es que ley
es es como decimos en inglés updated y
no hemos reformado la ley migratoria
desde la época de Urbano y estas son
congresos es responsabilidad del
Congreso y ejecutivo de tanto demócrata
como republicanos no hemos tenemos un
ley de acuerdo con la realidad y la
realidad es que hay presiones económicos
muy fuertes que están que están
manejando este flujo de inmigración y y
no estoy de acuerdo que es yo creo que
la la cuestión de seguridad nacional es
algo que utilicen los republicanos para
como herramienta de miedo estoy de
acuerdo como dice César los grandes
carteles de México no necesitan el flujo
de inmigrantes irregulares para meter
es más durante la época de Donald Trump
y ha subido debajo del señor Entonces el
problema es que tenemos demasiado gente
con demanda Entrar en este país
Buscando empleo buscando uno mejor vida
y no tenemos un sistema adecuado para
manejarlos no tenemos el presupuesto no
tenemos la cantidad de gente en la
frontera y no tenemos sistemas
judiciales eficientes para tratar con
ellos Entonces eso para mí es
fundamental y va a requerir un cambio de
ley pero el presidente está cumpliendo
con la ley como está escrito no hay duda
bueno para continuar un poco con este
debate si hay o no las medidas
suficientes y que como usted apunta
señor Lawrence hace falta personal hace
falta dinero hace falta control y la
respuesta un poco del gobierno biden es
decir uno un permiso humanitario que le
permite a las personas de Venezuela
Haití Cuba y Nicaragua que tengan
familiares y personas amigos en Estados
Unidos que puedan responder
económicamente por ellos que lo hagan y
así poder migrar también vaiden está
abriendo o abrirá más de 100 centros
regionales en distintos países de
América Latina para solicitar el asilo
desde los países de origen y evitar la
concentración en la frontera y hay otras
medidas como la creación de la
aplicación
cbp One en la cual los migrantes pueden
solicitar una cita con el personal de
aduanas y frontera antes de ir a la
frontera y finalmente la más reciente es
la nueva regla de asilo con la que le
está diciendo a los migrantes si ustedes
cruzaron por otros países antes de
llegar a Estados Unidos y en esos países
no solicitaron asilo en Estados Unidos
no lo podrán hacer y los vamos a
expulsar de manera inmediata frente a
esta última regla de asilo César Le
quiero preguntar esto en la práctica No
hará lo mismo que el título 42 que es
una expulsión inmediata sí De acuerdo
pragmáticamente sí efectivamente
funcionaría de la misma manera ahora
bien que se recrudezcan o que se
fortalezcan las medidas de
antimigración irregular si lo queremos
ver así no significa que no vamos a
tener problemas de migración irregular
en Estados Unidos Más allá de las
lógicas propuestas políticas de crear
estos centros digamos continentales
porque si lo vemos así hay uno en
Colombia que se ha creado efectivamente
para esto para la reunificación familiar
uno podría decir que son controles a
distancia no como si la geografía no es
muy interesante porque como si la
geografía o la distancia geográfica
sirviera para controlar un poco la
migración irregular pero vamos a dar
cuenta que independientemente de la del
recrudecimiento de las políticas de
antimigratorias en los Estados Unidos no
significa que no vaya a haber también
una diáspora o un flujo migratorio
irregular que se vaya a concentrar en la
frontera sur de los Estados Unidos esto
depende también incluso también de las
problemáticas continentales pobreza
hambre regímenes no democráticos a
situaciones humanitarias inclusive todo
lo tiene que ver con las lógicas del
crimen organizado que seamos énfasis
hace unos segundos Entonces yo creo que
esta esta dimensión o esta nueva
propuesta o más bien volver un poco al
título ocho lo que significa la práctica
es que efectivamente las políticas van a
ser siguiendo van a seguir estando por
la misma sintonía por la misma vía Y eso
digamos que refleja de alguna u otra
manera que la migración irregular no se
convierte tal vez en el dolor de cabeza
del hemisferio en este momento
Julio Usted qué opina seguirán en las
mismas medidas independientemente de que
se aplique el título 42 el título ocho o
las nuevas reglas de asilo seguirá
Estados Unidos cerrando sus fronteras o
usted no lo considera así
María Clara Mira
desde que yo recuerdo Yo estoy
escuchando
el mismo discurso acerca de la
inmigración ilegal que hay que resolver
que esto es un problema que las las
leyes pues no están adaptadas a los
tiempos Estoy escuchando todo esto
la la amnistía más grande que se hizo
los Estados Unidos la hizo un presidente
republicano
y eso Supuestamente iba a resolver todo
este problema pero vemos que no es el
caso y la razón es muy sencilla el resto
gran parte del mundo porque están
viniendo no solo de América Latina
estamos encontrando personas que vienen
de Bielorrusia debieran de China
el gran problema es que los Estados
Unidos no puede dar entrada todo lo que
vienen de países que no funcionan Como
quisiera yo le plantearía esto a a tus
otros dos invitados a ver estarían
contento con que con que Estados Unidos
digan que venga el que quiera o sea
cualquier país cualquier país en el
mundo que digan que entre el que quiera
vamos a eliminar fronteras y que voten
que hagan que reciban los derechos que
venga el que quiera estarían contento
con eso Porque muchos de estos discursos
buscapelar a las emociones porque son
personas porque son seres humanos Sí
pero en la raíz del problema proviene de
los sistemas que tienen en esos países o
sea de la cual los Estados Unidos no se
puede hacer responsable me parece
coherente y correcto que los Estados
Unidos busque establecer lazos
comerciales con países democráticos que
tienen problemas de de salidas de sus
ciudadanos Eso me parece correcto pero
muchos de estos problemas es violencia
por ejemplo que hay en esos países que
las autoridades las autoridades pues no
tienen la los mecanismos la voluntad
para frenarlo países donde hay gran
corrupción y corrupción que viene del
poder político Entonces los Estados
Unidos tiene un deber con sus ciudadanos
y la noción de un estado de derecho si
creemos en un estado de derecho es el
respeto por la ley la ley como están no
la ley como quisiéramos que fuera o la
ley como filósofos o poetas quisieran
que llegara a hacer eso muy romántico y
y yo les digo a los que realmente creen
eso por favor inviten a sus casas a
ilegales a vivir si estos O sea si estas
dos los dos invitados y lo uso ellos
como ejemplo yo ellos son
representativos de de un pensar que
abran sus casas y los dejen que quedó
adopten dos tres cuatro cinco
inmigrantes ilegales que les costé su
estadía que sean generosos Bondadosos
como quieren aparentar eso no lo van a
hacer eso
déjeme lo interrumpo para trasladarle
precisamente su pregunta a Lawrence
Lawrence Estados Unidos puede abrirle
las puertas a todos los migrantes o no
debe hacerlo
y no creo que nadie aquí o está
proponiendo eso ni la administración de
yopain tenemos lees y tenemos que
cumplir con los lees en ese momento no
son adecuados Mira yo estoy de acuerdo
en en cuestión de asilo yo creo que lo
hizo presente Trump que implementó La
regulación de esperar su tiempo en
México otro país fue correcto porque yo
antes antes de ser consultor de
diplomático norteamericano yo estaba
encargado de nuestro embajada en
Honduras por un rato y yo lo puedo
confirmar que los coyotes y la gente
aconsejando los migrantes para ir a
Estados Unidos dicen cruzan la frontera
declarar asilo y ellos te van a parar
unos minutos y soltar y no tiene que
aparecer por cuatro o cinco años frente
a un juez es una táctica utilizado Para
entrar Para migrantes económicos que
quieren una mejor vida entonces yo Yo
creo que la política que empezó
de exigir que la gente aplicara en otro
país y esperar su petición a otro país
es lo correcto y Es lógico y Esto va a
ayudar a frenar pero nadie está diciendo
Abre todas las fronteras no es que
tenemos un problema de demanda que es
excesivo y no tenemos la capacidad en
este momento conocermientos que tiene el
gobierno de frenarlo bajo las leyes
existentes y es que ahí radica
precisamente la diferencia del título 42
de cualquier otra medida Y es que hace
que los migrantes esperen la solicitud
de asilo por fuera de Estados Unidos
mientras que antes podrían hacerlo
estando en Estados Unidos y tal como lo
dice Lawrence es una de las tácticas
utilizadas por los coyotes y las redes
de tráfico de personas quiero volver con
usted César Ahora sí para tratar un tema
que ustedes estaban diciendo y es estas
el levantamiento del título 42 la
aplicación de las nuevas medidas y
también normas estatales que están
aplicando gobiernos republicanos por
ejemplo en Texas en Florida con rol de
santis todo también está enmarcado en un
contexto de Cara a las presidenciales
del próximo año en Estados Unidos qué
tan relacionadas están bueno Yo como en
política todo tiene unas conexiones
sistémicas No es interesante ver también
como lo decían ahorita hace un rato
también los políticos apelan a las
emociones hoy Efectivamente es muy
interesante y es una categoría que se
usa mucho en política y es empezar a
jugar de alguna u otra manera de una
forma muy mediática como esto genera
cierto tipo de respaldo ciudadanos Ahora
sí apelando a la legitimidad de los
digamos gobernadores o etcétera no que
están a cargo de este tipo de
territorios al sur de los Estados Unidos
y eso Funciona muy bien efectivamente
para demostrar que el gobierno
republicano o el gobierno local
republicano está haciendo que la gente
quiere que haga no un poco esas
dimensiones y ahora bien se trata
también de algo interesante y lo decía
ahorita mi compañero de panel y es no se
trata de entonces Mostrar que se abran
las fronteras y se acaba el estado y no
y se derrumbe en las fronteras no se
trata efectivamente de entender que en
efecto la rigidez de las políticas no va
directamente ligada a que se acabe la
migración irregular es más bien cómo
tratar el problema y dónde atacar las
causas subyacentes de los fenómenos no
se trata de ninguna manera de la
eliminación del estado Ni mucho menos
pero para responder tu pregunta sí
efectivamente usted puede funcionar como
una digamos un argumento electoral y un
argumento electoral apelando
efectivamente a lo que los ciudadanos
ven como su posible enemigo su posible
amenaza y su posible amenaza es un
migrante irregular que esté reemplazando
los puestos de trabajo o que esté
haciendo actividades Ay sí ilegales en
territorio estadounidense julio y en esa
dinámica que describe César quién es
ganarían más votos con el tema de la
migración los republicanos restringiendo
como ya lo están haciendo los estados
que mencioné o los demócratas con las
medidas de Joe biden
María Clara Eso está clarísimo o sea
está clarísimo porque estamos viendo
Incluso en
ciudades y territorios sólidamente
demócratas de izquierda pues quejarse de
lo que está ocurriendo en la frontera
Sur porque esto impacta al
estadounidense en grande particularmente
al estadounidense sin título
universitario es es una ironía porque
precisamente las minorías que viven en
los Estados Unidos en gran medida apoyan
el estado de derecho y el respeto a la
ley y no la entrada en masa como hemos
estado viendo los números no engañan o
sea en en los veintiséis veintisiete
meses que lleva Joe biden el poder han
entrado más personas que en los cuatro
años de Donald Trump o sea los números
ya relatan una
verídica y el descontento si creemos de
nuevo en el principio de una democracia
en el sentido de su representantes y la
voluntad popular Por supuesto que no
solo en Estados
[Música]
sólidamente republicanos sino también
por ejemplo en Texas tenemos
congresistas demócratas que están que
parece republicanos hablando o sea es
una inquietud porque deprime la entrada
de eliminación ilegal
deprime Los sueldos a los trabajadores a
la clase Obrera norteamericana
es un competidor particularmente para
estadounidenses de repito que no tienen
títulos universitarios los que los que
viven en las costas
con
negocios Tal vez sí les conviene la mano
de obra barata porque quisieran pagar
casi nada y si y si lo pagan ilegalmente
Pues básicamente es un subsuelo
perjudica al trabajador usted no nos
hablaba de las condiciones de los
estadounidenses frente a la migración a
lorens Le quiero preguntar qué pasa con
los migrantes del otro lado de la
frontera México acaba de firmar ahora en
mayo un nuevo pacto con Estados Unidos
en el que se compromete a seguir
recibiendo personas de Cuba Haití
Nicaragua y Venezuela que sean
expulsadas de Estados Unidos bajo el
título 8 Pero tiene las condiciones
México para recibir y seguir recibiendo
tanto flujo de migrantes y en qué
condiciones están ellos
bueno es eso es una preocupación
legítima que que México en ese momento
no parece que tiene las condiciones
adecuadas para recibirlas en una forma
que diríamos que sería más adecuado pero
al mismo tiempo en los Estados Unidos
tampoco tenemos suficiente
capacidad
de de mantener ese gente en situaciones
adecuadas y por eso los jueces están
mandando que es que se suelten en la
sociedad y ese ha causado un gran
problema como digo Julio en los en los
Estados sureños Entonces en este momento
es muy complicado y la esperanza es que
más gente tiene que esperar No solo en
México sino nosotros sitios de
latinoamérica donde pueden aplicar para
su su Estilo o su permiso Ahora sí entra
vamos a nuestra Ronda de conclusiones
porque se nos acaba el tiempo muy
brevemente en menos de un minuto
Lawrence cuál serían ustedes para usted
las consecuencias y cuál sería su
conclusión sobre el fin del título 42
yo creo que va a ser un periodo caótico
como ha dicho el secretario mallorcas
que hay muchas demandas mucha gente
llegando a las frontera esperando el fin
de eso y va a tomar un tiempo de de
organizarlo bien pero yo creo que al fin
y al cabo está haciendo la
administración va en lo correcto y han
título 42 ya no es adecuado ya no hay
esa crisis de salud y tenemos que
arreglar nuestro sistema bajo las leyes
de título ocho y el otro programa que
tiene los Estados Unidos para controlar
la migración y regular Julio su
conclusión
solo quiero señalar que mi fuente dentro
de la actual administración
estadounidense me han dicho que los
Estados Unidos le ha ofrecido a México
dinero por costear la estadía de esas
personas o sea que en parte la postura
que México ha expresado se debe a que
los Estados Unidos pues se le ha
asegurado que le va a remunerar por esa
ese cuidado me parece que es desastroso
me parece que es desastroso que hay una
crisis Sur bastante peligrosa no pueden
divorciar el fenómeno de que la 90% de
la droga está entrando por esa por esa
vía y que los carteles de las drogas son
los que están controlando las frontera
Sur en gran medida en el tránsito yo
creo que eso o sea grandes
preocupaciones del tráfico de humano del
abuso a menores y todo esto y sin
embargo el tener una puerta abierta de
inmigración es una invitación a ese tipo
de abuso esto hay que frenarlo y
frenarlo es rápido la primera parte de
su respuesta hacía alusión al control a
distancia de la migración del que nos
hablaba César César su conclusión bueno
la situación se va a empeorar yo creo
que esto va a generar una tensión en la
frontera sur de unas envergaduras
altísimas no obstante significará
también un termómetro para la
administración de cómo resuelve esto y
esto Tal vez seguramente será el inicio
de su discurso tal vez de cierre en los
próximos años de su
presidencia y también será un asunto
como ver y cómo trata el asunto
migratorio el presidente biden
finalmente yo creo que es un asunto en
el que tiene que ver que la el
reconocimiento de medidas no significará
el fin de la migración irregular y que
habrá que tener una atención especial
sobre las gobernanzas criminales que hay
en la frontera Sur con los Estados
Unidos y contrario a que signifique el
fin de la migración podría todo traer un
aumento disparado en la cantidad de
migrantes muy brevemente hacemos la
última ronda seguramente Sí yo creo que
insisto el número de migrantes no va a
cambiar por las medidas que se pongan en
la frontera en la en los Estados Unidos
Yo creo que la migración tiene que ver
con otro tipo de patrones con otro tipo
de fenómenos que se nos olvidan las
causas de Por qué la gente migra de
manera irregular Julio se disparará a la
migración en Estados Unidos por supuesto
que sí Por supuesto que sí y yo creo que
hay un un trasfondo y donde deben estar
los procuradores los fiscales
particularmente los norteamericanos
viendo quién está financiando todo este
transportación de personas o sea porque
son recursos que algunas entidades
tienen que estarle dedicando porque
muchas de estas personas vienen de
países por ejemplo de medio de África
que no tienen un centavo Cómo es que
cruzan medio continente cuando aquí
sabemos el costo que tiene todo yo creo
que ustedes son preguntas que hay que
hacerse Y por supuesto que la palabra se
extiende se riega y cuando hay una
política que es
es igual y esto lo vemos en el crimen
cuando los fiscales no están reforzando
la ley y permiten que roben hasta mil
quinientos dólares pues vemos un alza en
el robo hasta mil quinientos dólares y
en este caso la analogía es que están
entrando en masa y esto busquen en las
redes y van a ver ayer mismo como las
frontera está abierta y agentes de
seguridad están señalando a que se
apuren y que entren al territorio
estadounidense
se disparará en la
migración Sí yo creo que efectivamente
Este cambio va a causar Un aumento
dramático en el corto plazo pero yo creo
que en el mediano y largo plazo si va a
estabilizar pasado en las condiciones
económicas que hay en los Estados Unidos
Comparado con la región perfecto César
niño Julio m schilling y Lawrence
gambiner Gracias por estar con nosotros
y a ustedes también gracias por
sintonizarnos y yo les agradezco el
nombre de todo nuestro equipo técnico la
producción del debate estuvo a cargo de
Andrés doncell y la de los invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera sigan dejando sus
comentarios y sigan conectados
[Música]